[Music]
welcome everybody to miltonis world of
t-cells solutions to enhance your t-cell
experiments
in the next 50 minutes i will give you a
short introduction to our company
the role of t-cells in general and the
concept of t-cell workflows
as well as pointing out our t-cell
highlight applications
so let's begin with a brief company
presentation
milton biotech was founded in 1989 by
stefan milton himself
and is the largest owner managed company
in germany
we have two main sites in germany one in
bergschlabbach
where the headquarters are located and
one in tetoro where the gmp
manufacturing facility is located
we have subsidiaries in 28 countries and
distribute to additional 73 countries
currently we employ over 3 000 employees
worldwide our mission is to serve the
needs in life science research
and to translate new scientific findings
into clinical applications
let's have a brief look at t-cells and
why they are so important
t-cells play as a factors of the immune
system an integral role to the adaptive
immunity
they can be subdivided broadly into
several phenotypically and functionally
distinct subsets
such as the helper cells cytotoxic t
killer cells
deregulatory cells as well as the rather
heterogenic group of unconventional t
cells comprising for example natural
killer t cells
and gamma delta t cells t cells are the
only immune cells that are able to form
a long lasting immunological memory
that helps to respond fast and more
efficient to already experience threats
key surface markers are of course the
lineage markers cd3
as well as cd4 and cd8 but also
activation markers
such as cd25 cd69 cd 137
and cd 154 t cells communicate and
exert their functions mainly via
cytokines such as il2
il4 tnf alpha and interferon gamma
t cells are most relevant in both
maintenance of health as well
as fighting diseases last but not least
these properties make t-cells ideal
tools for immunotherapy
where for example t cells are
genetically modified
into car t cells to attack specifically
cancer cells
although our best known products are
indeed the microbeads and isolation kits
we are not
just a cell separation company we
actually cover the whole experimental
diesel workflow
from cell separation to cell analysis
including also sample preparation
as well as cell culture we provide
thereby solutions for each step of your
experiment
so our t-cell portfolio is indeed large
one way to keep a good overview is to
divide our t-cell products into our
different main workflow technologies
sample preparation for everything that
has to do with preparing your sample
for example tissue or blood before you
isolate your t
cells and you start your experiment the
gentlemax tissue dissociator
and the tissue dissociation kits are
here the hallmark products
cell separation our classical microbeads
and isolation kits in all their variants
to isolate efficiently t cells and
subsets
cell culture everything needed to
culture
activate and expand your t-cells from
media to cytokines to antigens
diesel antibodies flow kits but also
instruments for flow analysis
sorting and even imaging
well although it's now easier to get an
overlook
we thought that maybe the best way to
arrange our large t-cell portfolio are
distinct workflows
specifically designed for your
experimental needs
thereby we cover as focused workflows
amongst others
regulatory t cells car t cell research
gamma delta t cells tumor infiltrating
leukocytes
polarization of t cells antigen and
virus specific t cells
and of course activation and expansion
of t cells
with these comprehensive workflows you
can easily choose the products relevant
for your specific field of interest
getting your whole workflow from miltoni
biotech means
ease of mind standardization
reproducibility
and organization of an experimental
workflow become much
more feasible miltoni biotech as
supplier for the whole t
cell workflow means that all reagents
fulfill the same high quality criteria
and the order process can be streamlined
thereby harmonizing the steps of an
experiment
as well as automation and upscaling are
easily performed
getting all products from miltoni
biotech guarantees
smooth procedures and less errors since
for example our cell separation is
tested for compatibility with our flow
cytometry
and our media for compatibility with our
cytokines
and so forth moreover having miltoni
biotech as full supplier for the whole
workflow
means also getting full support for
every step of your experiment
thanks to our great scientific support
team
moreover a hallmark feature of miltoni
biotech's workflow solutions
is the seamless translation from a
research setting into a clinical setting
and back thanks to our max gmp portfolio
as well as manufacturing platforms such
as the clinimax prodigy
well let's start our journey through the
tesol workflow taking the first step
sample preparation every successful
experiment starts with a proper sample
preparation
so start smart
so your samples need to be prepared
accordingly before starting your t-cell
experiment
this is especially true when working
with human and mouse solid
tissue keep in mind the quality of
sample preparation
influences all downstream applications
for example a homogeneous and viable
single cell suspension
is the basis for successful and
efficient cell separation
multni biotech sample preparation
solutions namely the gentlemax tissue
dissociator and the respective tissue
dissociation kits combine efficient
automated mechanical tissue disruption
with gentle and tissue-specific
enzymatic digestion
with this you obtain an optimal single
cell suspension
with t cells of highest viability and
preserved epitopes
for the subsequent cell separation
streamlined sample preparation with the
gentlemax ensures
optimal reproducibility in downstream
compatibility
the gentlemax hereby is programmable has
optional
automated heating and can process up to
8 samples in parallel
eliminating thereby user variability
here we have a good example of the
efficiency of the dental max
dissociation
preparing t cell from mouse colons has
been challenging
as the commonly used protocol is labor
intensive and often results in low cell
yield
using the gentlemax in combination with
the laminar appropriate dissociation
kits
enables to standardize the workflow and
obtain consistently higher numbers of
t-cells
than with homebrew or manual methods
in the top left dot plots of cd4 and
cd8t cells
you see how efficiently the tissue
dissociation
of mouse lamina propria is performed is
the gentlemax and the respective enzyme
kits
weld well distinct cell populations are
visible and staining with cd3
cd4 cd8a and cd49b
antibodies followed by analysis on the
maxwell analyzer
show a consistently high numbers of
viable t t-cells
however even more rare and delicate
cells like t-rex
can be prepared with maximum efficiency
using the gentlemax and the laminar
propia kit
as you can see on the lower left two
methods were compared
first the gentlemax protocol using the
laminar proper kit
and then the gentlemax respective
program
and second the manual method which means
cut the tissue into smaller pieces add
fetal barbarian serum
add different enzymes and incubate for
an extended
period of time subsequently
analysis of cd4 positive fox p3 positive
t-rex cells in the cell suspension was
performed
on the max point analyzer analysis
not only revealed that the efficient
gentlemax dissociation resulted in
distinct and viable cell populations as
seen in panel a
but also that consistently more t-rex
are obtained comparing to the manual
method
as seen in panel b the last example on
the right
shows preparation of tumor infiltrating
leukocytes from b16
f10 melanoma mouse tumors again
comparing dissociation with the
gentlemax protocol
and mechanical manual dissociation
without enzymes
the cell suspensions were subsequently
stayed with reaffinity recombinant
antibodies for till markers such as tim3
pd1 and luxory
it can clearly be seen that the yield of
viable target cells is up to five times
higher using the gentlemax system
than with the competitor method in
summary the gentlemax and kits ensure
high cell yield and away and viability
even from hard to process tissue
as depicted in the small info box on the
lower right
apart from the lamina propria mouse kit
we of course
also offer other dedicated tissue
dissociation kits
to get highly viable t-cells from
example from spleen
lung liver and tumors tissue
now once your sample is properly
prepared it is time for the next step
the separation of your t-cells of course
here our renowned mux technology is the
way to go
so select the best for all your cell
separation needs
cell separation poses many challenges to
the researcher
high purity and recovery are of course
important but also reproducibility
cell viability and compatibility
downstream applications
have to be ensured furthermore there is
a variety of different t-cell subtypes
that might be of interest and have to be
separated individually
some of them display very low
frequencies in the variety of different
starting materials hard to obtain
and of course cell separation should be
fast and easy to use
consequently there are many cell
separation challenges and pain points to
face
gladly melting biotech offers the right
solutions for all of them
generally mug cell separation technology
offers two different separation
strategies
first positive selection with our
microbeads and microbead kits
target cells are hereby labeled and
directly selected their specific and
defining marker
as target cells are still magnetically
labeled after separation
they're usually not suited for an
additional round of sub separation
except when you use rear lease
microbeads where the label can be
removed by
an additional step this positive
selection approach
via microbeads is very specific and
therefore ideally suited for
rare cells or undefined single cell
suspensions
such as tumors as well as other
difficult
or compromised samples for example when
working with patient material
also isolation dyram whole blood and
products is very well achieved with max
positive
selection second we have the
untouched isolation with our isolation
kits
working with the depletion of non-target
cells
this is necessary when the target cell
fraction is not defined by a certain
marker
but rather the lack thereof hereby all
cells
expressing defined exclusion markers are
depleted
and the target cells remain unlabeled
and thus are usable for further rounds
of sub-separation
however in order to work efficiently the
single cell suspension
has to be rather well defined as it is
the case for example with human pbmcs
or mouse single cell spleen suspensions
taken together different isolation
strategies allow to get the most out of
your sample
with milton e biotech being an expert in
all cell separation strategies
playing with and combining the different
approaches offers a great flexibility
according to your needs and is the
secret to success
consequently mug cell separation
technology
comes with four different approaches to
perfectly reflect the different starting
materials
first we have microbeads and microbit
kits
that are ideal for positive t cell
selection from pbmcs and various tissue
single cell suspensions
they also include a new release
technology for label-free cell
separation
separation of basic t-cells in almost
any t-cell subtype from different
species like human
mouse red and non-human primate make
microbeads and microbead kits
the most versatile cell separation
approach
second we have isolation kits that are
ideal for all
untouched separation needs the use
starting material
are pbmcs or defined single cell
suspensions alter the isolation kits
cover basic t-cells as well as
almost any tesla subtypes from different
species like human
mouse red and non-human primate
however if you do not want to go over
the density gradient to get bbmcs a
starting material
you can now also isolate t cells fast
and directly
from whole blood and blood products so
a third option we have our straight from
microbead kits
for the isolation of human cd3 cd4
and cd8 t cells directly from whole
blood and blood products
without the need for density gradient
centrifugation
it is a reliable way to get your t cells
fast and easy
and of course automatable
as for separation variant we offer max
express
isolation kits also here human t-rex
pan-t cells as well as cd4 and cd8
subsets and even cd4 memory t cells
can be isolated directly from whole
blood and blood products
without the need for density gradient
centrifugation
this time however it is an untouched
cell isolation approach
max express is not automatable though
but indeed very fast and uncomplicated
one of the many things that sets miltoni
biotech's t-cell portfolio apart
is its broadness and diversity we cover
more than just the basic human and mouse
diesel subtypes
indeed over 70 t-cell separation
products
cover virtually every t-cell subset
addressing t-cells
researchers needs worldwide for example
different naive and memory t-cell
subtypes as well as t-cell
t-helper cell subtypes are covered
furthermore
different t-regulatory cells gamma delta
t cells and
nkt cell separation kits are available
as well as complete workflows for
antigen specific t cells
cytokine secreting t cells and car t
cell research
and many many more
apart from human and mouse samples we
also offer t-cell separation kits for
red
and non-human primate samples as
scientists we understand how important
it is
to address the full complexity of t-cell
subtypes
even for the rare ones and to offer
according solutions
in the following slides i will give you
an overview of the most important diesel
separation products
including our highlights
but why use miltoni biotech for cell
enrichment and what does make
max cell separation technology so
special
in short our select the best approach
minimal labeling
with no effects on psychology for full
downstream compatibility
in more detail this is due to the
columns as technological advantage
the columns amplify the magnetic field
by 10 000 fold
this allows for minimal labeling and
smaller speed sizes
of only 50 nanometers in consequence
less epitopes are covered on the cell
surface and less stress is applied on
the cells
so a thousands of publications prove the
isolated t cells are fully suited for
any downstream application
including flow analysis thereby max
microbeads were even approved by the fda
to be used in a specific clinical
setting
it is important to note that the column
allows for the most gentle
sorting since there is a large space
between the steel spheres
of the column matrix with about 20 times
the size of lymphocytes
the t cells will pass through smoothly
without any negative effect
have a look at the data on the right
side we see these relabeled t-cells
column-free technology results in beat
aggregates in cell culture and
massive over-labeling on the cell
surface with max column technology
you see no bead aggregates and minimal
labeling for fully functions
and indeed you see also in these western
blots that t
cells are not activated after cell
isolation with max technology
cd4 t cells were isolated with either
positive selection or negative selection
using max technology
or column three competitors methods
their activation status was then
assessed by lysing the different
isolated t cell samples
and performing a western blot for map
kinase phosphorylation
a reliable activation status marker on
the left side
you see a western blood for p38
phosphorylation
after positive isolation of cd4 t cells
using either
milton e cd4 microbeads human
or two column-free competitor systems
untreated and lps treated supt-1 cells
served as negative and positive control
respectively
it can be clearly seen that cells
isolated with max technology
yield a much lower fossil p38 expression
than cells isolated with the
competitor's column tech
free technology on the right
side you see a western blot for junk 1
and 2 phosphorylation
after negative isolation of cd4 cells
and t cells using either multiness cd4 t
cell isolation kit human
or 3 column 3 competitor systems
also here untreated and lps treated
supt-1 cells
served as negative and positive control
respectively
again it can be clearly seen that cells
isolated this max technology
yield much lower phosphor junkiness 1
and 2 expression
than cells isolated with the
competitor's column 3 technology
both western blots clearly show that
cell separation with max technology is
the most gentle
one and does not activate t cells
regardless of positive or negative
selection
the first highlight cell separation
products are our t
cell isolation kits for the untouched
isolation of various human and mouse t
cell subsets
of course the kits offer our well-known
high purity in recovery
however also a very important factor is
of course the protocol speed
especially with untouched isolation
faster protocol times are favored
miltoni biotech offers therefore a total
of 17
fast cell isolation kits that allow to
isolate publication quality target cells
in
only 18 minutes
the six mouse fast isolation kits
comprise the most important t-cell
subsets
as well as two b-cell kits the 11 human
fast isolation kits also cover the most
important t-cell subsets
as well as b-cells nk cells and
monocytes
so instead of long and tedious
processing we offer fast and easy
protocols
however it does not stop with the
isolation kits
also our best-selling mouse microbeads
were improved
and the protocols updated by reducing
tedious washing steps and optimizing
incubation times in three easy steps you
get from spleen to target cells in less
than 15 minutes
simply straightforward cd4 and cd8 mouse
t
cells as well as cd 90.1 mouse and red t
cells and also c90.2
mouse t cells can now be isolated by a
positive selection in only 13.5 minutes
using our updated microbeads mouse
of course with the ever appreciated
quality and purity
it is an easy and fast protocol that can
be fully automated
on the automax pro or the multi-mix each
micro bit kit
has a high capacity for 2 times 10 to
the 9's total cell
which corresponds to up to 20 mouse
splits
consequently with the high sample
capacity and automation options
the updated microbeads mouse are not
only economic but also very efficient
and therefore ideally suited for the
processing of high sample numbers
have a look at the product page by
following the links above
here you will find scientific posters
highlighting the advantages of max
microbeads
for example in mouse adoptive t cell
transfer experiments
and again it does not matter if you use
positive or negative selection
cell separation with max technology is
fully downstream compatible
and has no effects on cell biology in
either case
year t cells were either positively
selected with cd4 or cd8 microbits mouse
or isolated untouched with our own
respective diesel isolation kits
directly after isolation day zero and
after one day of cultivation
with and without stimulation using the
t-cell activation expansion kit
marked with plus and minus respectively
activation markers cd25 and cd69 were
analyzed by flow cytometry
to assess potential activation
as you can see without stimulation cells
are neither activated when separated
positively with the microbeads
nor when isolated untouched with the
isolation kits
this means that both cell isolation
methods are equally gentle
when stimulated on purpose with the
diesel activation expansion kit
cells are highly activated and
upregulate accordingly
cd25 and cd69 regardless of the
isolation strategy
meaning that both isolation methods are
equally suited for functional downstream
applications
consequently both approaches do not
affect cell biology and
ensure full t-shell functionality while
ensuring fast and gentle isolation
as a useful tip we observed that red
blood cell lysis indeed activates t
cells
however red blood cell lysis is not
needed
for t cell isolation with max microbeads
from mouse spleen
so better avoid it
our next highlight product are the
straight from microbeads
straight from microbeads allow the
isolation of target cells
directly from blood and blood products
without density gradient centrifugation
in regards to t cells cd3 cd4
and cd8 positive cells are covered and
can be directly isolated from whole
blood buffer coil
leuko-reduction system chambers
abbreviated lrsc
and glucopex of course cell separation
with straight from is automatable
this means processing on either automax
pro or multi-max
are possible and reduces processing time
for example
of a whole buffer code to only 30
minutes
indeed protocols need to be fast and
easy especially for larger screening
purposes
automation and high throughput options
may be desirable
furthermore starting materials in this
case blood products
come in different formats so a
restriction here is not desirable
moreover sometimes samples and cell
numbers are limited
so of course cell loss especially when
working with small or rare samples
must be minimized but purity maximized
however most importantly cells must not
be activated by isolation
to ensure that for example really only
the specifically stimulated t cells
proliferate and are fully functional
straight from is the ideal solution here
a
fast and flexible positive isolation
approach that allows to isolate
different cell types from the same
sample with minimal loss
due to the skipping of density gradient
centrifugation
to date the most widely used method to
isolate target cells from whole blood
and blood products is
however performing still density
gradient centrifugation for the
generation of pbm sales
first followed by cell separation of the
target cell subtypes
apart from the time consuming protocol
with two hours with over two hours
processing time
the handling is rather complicated and
does not allow for automation
furthermore a significant amount of
target cells
may be easily lost in a user-dependent
fashion
in addition harsh and long handling as
well as some gradient media
may also affect the cells at least to
some degree
so act carefully the alternative to
density gradient centrifugation is
multiney biotech straight from
technology
hereby cells can be directly isolated
from blood products in a fast and easy
way
without density gradient centrifugation
cell counting and washing
the produce the procedure is fast but
gentle and can be fully automated
so from sample to target cells in only
30 minutes processing time
this is of course also backed up by flow
cytometry data
and assessment of activation marker
expression
cd4 and cd8 t cells were isolated from a
buffy code either with straight from cd4
cd8 microbeads on the left side
or by a density gradient centrifugation
followed by a competitor's untouched
palm t-cell isolation
on the right side cells were analyzed
for activation marker expression of cd25
and cd69 either directly after cell
isolation
day zero or after one or two days of
cultivation
either without stimulus or stimulated
with the diesel activation and expansion
kit
labeled with minus or plus respectively
cells isolated with straight from show
almost no activation marker expression
even after two days of culture
however when activated on purpose using
the t-cell activation expansion kit
this sells highly upregulated cd25 and
cd69
showing their biological functionality
cells isolated by density gradient
centrifugation
followed by a competitor's untouched
pawn t cell isolation
instead show activation marker
expression from the beginning on
and consequently may not be efficiently
activated in downstream applications
such as polyclonal or specific
activation
our next t-cell separation highlight are
the real-lease microbead kits
this revolutionary microbead technology
allows to positively select cells but
then to remove
the microbeads and the antibody labeling
to get completely label-free cells
release microbid kits are available for
many human and mouse t
cells and non-t cell subtypes including
markers such as
cd3 cd4 cd8 cd19
cd25 cd56 cd62l
cd 90.1 and 2 pd1 and tcr gamma delta
this offers researchers an entirely new
level of flexibility and new separation
strategies
combining the best of two worlds highly
specific positive selection
but if needed label free for example for
further subset separations
the procedure itself is quite easy after
cell separation
there is a beat removal step with the
beat release reagent
cells are now ready for a second round
of magnetic
an additional optional step can be
applied
using the release reagent to also remove
the bound
antibodies thus to obtain completely
label-free cells and make all epitopes
accessible again
the advantages of rear lease do not end
here
realise is so gentle and minimally
invasive due to the special structure of
the rear lease complex
that even cell isolation by a cd-3 does
not activate
t cells regardless of the labor removal
as you can see in this graph of isolated
human serious repositive t cells on the
left side
activation marker cd69 is not
upregulated
amongst pre-gated cd4 cells neither
after cds relabeling
nor after isolation nor after labor
release
however when activating the cells on
purpose cd69 is nicely upregulated
please note that pre-gating on cd8
positive cells
showed the same results
the example on the right shows a
multi-step subset isolation using
realists
first cd4 t cells are pre-selected
then the label is removed and cells are
ready for a second round of deeper
subset separation
in this case via cd25 for t-reg
isolation
further examples include gamma delta t
cells as well as cd3 negative
and k cells
finally i want to point out a cell
separation product
that is absolutely unique the cytokine
secretion assays
they allow to detect and enrich viable
cytokine secreting cells from mouse and
human samples
cytokines are immobilized on the surface
of the secreting cell
by the so-called catch reagent basically
the cell labels itself with its own
cytokines
in a second step the immobilized
cytokines are then labeled with spluro4
conjugated antibodies
called detection reagent and can then be
detected viably
without intracellular staining on any
flow cytometer
in an optional third step the
fluorophore-labeled
cytokine secreting cells can be
specifically enriched
and used in downstream assays by using
anti-fluorophore magnetic beads
consequently our cytokine secretion
assays come in two versions
for flow detection only we have the
detection kits for the separation of
viable
cytokinesic cells we have the detection
and enrichment kits including the
additional enrichment step
via a max column
max technology offers depending on the
researchers needs
different manual and automated cell
separation options for upscaling
manual separation with the quadrant
octomarks
for up to four or eight samples in
parallel respectively
automated upscaling options include the
automax pro
for full walk away convenience for up to
five samples
the multimax cell 24 separator plus for
the processing of up to 24 samples in
parallel
and finally the multimax x for flexible
fully automated high throughput
industrial applications with any source
material
now every researcher can reliably
automate cell separation
for more efficient workflows and higher
consistency
of course the automation options are
applicable to most of our t-cell
separation solutions
now we successfully isolated t-cells it
may be time
for the culture step of your experiment
so cultivate your vision
when culturing t cells apart from
activation expansion
also differentiation into different
t-cell subtypes is an important topic
the letter is performed in cytokines and
functional grade antibodies
activation is performed with either
polyclonal stimulation reagents
that for example engage cd3 in cd28
or antigen specifically using for
example our peptivator peptide pools
expansion and culturing is best
performed in special diesel media
such as our serum free tex max
in the following slides we will have a
more detailed look at milton in
biotech's t-cell culture portfolio
of course culture media play for the
cultivation of t-cells a pivotal role
here we offer our serum free tex-mex
t-cell medium
free of animal-derived components it is
available from research grade up to max
gmp grade
and ensures optimal t-cell growth
activation
and expansion tedious pre-testing of
expensive and rare fetal bovine serum is
not needed
and undesired side effects caused by the
serum are eliminated
originally tex-max was developed for the
clinical-grade serum free manufacturing
of human car t cells
however tex max in research grade is of
course also beneficial for many
other t-cell applications especially
human ones
moreover for the polarization of mouse
t-cells
tex-max has been proven to yield
superior results when compared to
standard basil medium
the serum free tex-max diesel medium
allows for most consistent t-cell
culture results
with the max gmp version and of course
with our expertise
translation into t clinics has never
been easier
talking about t cell activation and
expansion our classical beat based
expansion reagents
the diesel activation and expansion kits
offer a reliable yet flexible
pony global t-cell activation
of course specific diesel activation and
expansion kits for mouse and human
t-cells
and t-rex are available on top we also
offer a non-human primate version
the employed maxi beats can thereby be
flexibly loaded with biotinylated
antibodies of choice to optimize
activation stimuli as seen in the graphs
both mouse and human expansion rates
surpass very well 100 fold
for both cd4 and cd8 t cells
diesel activation expansion kits are not
only consistent in their performance
but also very economically priced
especially when considering the highest
cell capacity per kit
our next polyclonal diesel activation
expansion reagent
is the new and absolutely innovative t
cell transact human
it is a polymeric nanomatrix that
efficiently and reliably
sells cd3 cd28 engagement
as you can see in the dot plots on the
right displaying
strong up regulation for activation
markers
cd25 and cd69 in both cd4
and cd8 t cells after stimulation with
transact
as a nanomatrix transact is as
convenient as it gets
ready to use easy volumetric dosage and
simple removing by washing
so no tedious debating step is necessary
which makes transact compatible to
automated cell manufacturing systems
and minimizes cell loss being available
also in max gmp grade
transact is the ideal t-cell activation
reagent for automated and streamlined
translational applications such as car
t-cell manufacturing
so t-cell transact resolves quite some
pain points right away
it's easy to handle reliable and
consistent in performance
as well as easy to translate into
clinics
for the best activation expansion our
specific t-cell medium tex-mex and our
efficient activation solutions
namely the diesel activation expansion
kits and t-cell transacts
go of course hand-in-hand as you can see
on the left
tex-mex outperforms serum free
competitors and rpmi
alike in a 14-day human t-cell culture
after activation with the t-cell
activation expansion kitsch
reaching over 80-fold expansion without
the addition of serum
on the right side you see how efficient
the tex-mex and t-cell transect combined
work
in a completely serum free fully
translational cell culture setting
after 14 days of culture human t-cells
activate this t-cell transect in a serum
free tex-mex
even puff outperform a competitor's
classical beat mediated diesel
activation
in rpmi with 10 fetal provide serum
being thereby more reproducible
convenient and
translational
our third and last option for polyclonal
st cell stimulation is cytostem
the non-toxic staphylococcus enterotoxin
b
abbreviated sab alternative
cytostem crosslinks the t cells tcr to
the antigen presenting cells mhc
this means as with cb the t cells
need the presence of antigen presenting
cells to be stimulated properly
with cytostem this is best achieved in a
pbmc setting
and may serve for example as a
functional control
in antigen specific t cell experiments
since the receptor crosslinking of
cytostem is antibody mediated
no toxic super antigen like scb is
involved
however the efficiency is very well
comparable to acb as you can see
very well in the dot plots below so with
cytostem
no complicated to handle and dangerous
reagent is needed
but we offer a simple to use and
efficient alternative
another way to activate t cells is the
antigen-specific stimulation
for example using peptide pools please
remember
this also works best in the presence of
antigen presenting cells for example in
a pbmc context
or in a core culture of t cells and
antigen presenting cells
hereby the most efficient
antigen-specific stimulation of t-cells
is achieved reliably
with our peptivated peptide pools
these extensive panels of virus tumor
fungi microbiota or autoantigens
consist of 50 mere peptides with 11
amino acid overlaps
covering the complete sequence of the
respective antigen
the peptide composition ensures the
optimal stimulation of both cd4 and cd8
t
cells peptidators are available in
different quality grades
as well as in a convenient 96 well
format
for high throughput applications
the different quality grades include
research grade premium grade and max gmp
grade
most notably we recently added sarskoff
2peptivators to our portfolio
to support your research best in these
difficult times
please follow the respective links to
get to the peptivada product pages
as well as the sarskoff2peptivator video
please note that we also offer tlr
ligands
as well as recombinant full proteins for
cell stimulation
to stimulate and differentiate t cells
miltoni biotech offers
also max cytokines they come in three
different quality
grades mark stream p grade premium grade
and research grade research grade is the
standard quality format
and enables reliable and cost-effective
studies with human and mouse and red
cells
use premium-grade cytokines for most
consistent cell cultural results
pm grade cytokines offer the convenience
of well-defined
lot-specific biological activities in
international units
according to vho standards
thereby they allow for exact unit dosing
and eliminate
laborious lot pre-testing this
saves money but also time
max gmp cytokines come with extensive
documentation
lowest endotoxin content and highest
purity
ideal for relevant pre-clinical studies
and an easy translation into clinics
so indeed standardization is the key for
reliable cell culture results
talking about convenience and
consistency the cytobox's mouse
are kits that allow for the easiest
polarization of naive
cd4 positive mouse t cells
into th1 th2 and th17 subtypes
without complicated ordering and
calculation of single polarization
cocktail components
the cytobaxes contain in one convenient
kit
everything needed for the efficient
mouse dehydra cell polarization
including the cytokines and functional
grade antibodies
as you see in clearly in the presented
data
th1 th2 and th7t cells
are successfully polarized and expressed
their respective signature cytokines and
transcription factors
such as interferon gamma il-4 and il-17
as well as t-bed gutter 3 and raw gamma
t
respectively as you can see below best
results are of course generated
with our special t-cell medium tex-mex
our final chapter covers t-cell analysis
the method of choice is of course flow
cytometry for assessing t cell surface
markers
secreted cytokines and transcription
factors
miltoni biotech's extensive flow
analysis portfolio
not only includes antibodies but also
flow kits
cytometers sorters and even imaging
system
certifying here by every researcher's
need
so join the flow revolution
our first highlight product in the flow
chapter are the reaffinity recombinant
antibodies
being recombinantly engineered we have
full over their genetic sequence
and can express their affinity
antibodies in a mammalian
non-hybridoma cell system this means
that reaffinity antibodies
exhibits highest purity and lot a lot
consistency for even greater
reproducibility
that they can undergo a more stringent
in the house validation
and that there is no need for tedious
and costly fc resorptor blocking
and require only one iron universal
isotype control
for maximum convenience and cost saving
reaffinity antibodies are hereby readily
available in hundreds of specificities
and are best combined with our propriety
viodi fluorescent antibody conjugates
thereby wired eyes are bright with
superior mean fluorescence intensity
for excellent signals distinct with a
high staining index for clear population
discrimination
and hassle-free since they are ideal for
multi-color experiments
due to low compensation all this makes
reaffinity antibodies the ideal choice
for any flow analysis
since traditional hybridomas are not
standardized by nature
here i'd like to show you very briefly
just some exemplary flow antibodies that
you can choose from to create your own
panel
depending in which context you want to
analyze your t cells be it development
activation exhaustion or any other
phenotyping
with our convenient antibody panel
builder this goes even easier
just follow the link below and try out
this nifty
web-based software tool
however we do not only offer antibodies
but also convenient ready to use flow
analysis kits
such as the rapid cytokine inspector
kits
as all-in-one no-worries solutions that
combine
surface marker staining with
intracellular cytokine staining
for the analysis of activated cd4 and
cd8 t
cells in the fastest way possible
max black cytokine kits for determining
concentrations of up to 12 different
secreted cytokines
in cell culture supernatants and finally
the 8 color immunophenotyping kits for
flow evaluation of various leukocyte
subsets for example
monocytes neutrophils iozenofields
and tb and nk cells
importantly all of these kits are
compatible with the fast and convenient
express modes
on the maxquant analyzers these software
modules
automate analysis and thereby not only
speed it up
but also eliminate human error thanks to
automated gating and analysis templates
make sure to have a look at the new
promo video for the flow kits
as well as the express mode and maxplex
webinars by following the
respective links on the right
one of our highlight flow analysis kits
is depicted here
the sarskoff 2 t-cell analysis kit human
this all-in-one kit allows the efficient
and sensitive analysis of sarskoff ii
reactive t cells in human pbmc
samples after stimulation with our
sarskoff ii peptivator peptide pools
cells are stained with an optimized flow
panel depicted on the upper right side
and analyzed for example on our max
point flow analyzer
the kit includes a sarskoff 2 peptivator
of your choice
as well as the whole antibody panel and
all needed buffers and controls
as you can see we can beautifully detect
for example interferon gamma expressing
sarskoff 2 reactive
cd4 and cd8 t cells after stimulation
with a mix
of our sarskoff 2 pectivators
other markers as depicted in the panel
of course can also be assessed
our flow portfolio is rounded off with
our flow analysis in sorting instruments
of the max quant series first we have
the max quant analyzer powerful benchtop
flow cytometers with up to 16
optical parameters the clue here is that
they allow for full automated
acquisition
using a robotic sample collector with
and with the express modes
software modules even data analysis is
automated
and free of human error the small
benchtop cytometers fit easily under the
flow hood adding further to
operator safety for example when working
with contaminated samples
second we want tie to cells order
opposed to classical droplet sorters the
max quantity
allows for the most gentle cell sorting
and highest viability
even for rare and fragile cells thanks
to its unique microchip sorting
technology
furthermore the closed and serial
cartridge system
makes the title the idyllic machine for
a gmp environment
in this context i'd like to have a
closer look at our max1 title cell
sorter the gentleman under the cell
sorters
with its unique capabilities namely the
most gentle sorting and the closed
sterile cartridge system
the title is ideal for a gmp clinical
environment
not only in the fields of car t cells
and t-rex but
also for antigen and virus-specific t
t-cells
so let me point out that the title is
already part of several clinical cancer
trials
involving antigen or better set in this
case
tumor-specific t-cells
worthwhile mentioning is of course also
the title safety
in virus research the title works
without internal fluidics
and applies a sterile enclosed cartridge
system for maximum operator safety
sorting purity is of course guaranteed
as you can see
in the example below where car positive
t cells were sorted
after expansion in staining with our car
detection reagent
to over 99 purity
but the instrument highlights do not end
here
a really fantastic novelty in our
portfolio
are our new imaging systems maxima
and the ultra microscope light sheet
microscope family
these systems allow the visualization of
t cells and others
within a tissue context thereby
new cartiba car t targets may be
identified
the distribution dynamics of tilts in
tumor
tissue assessed and a deep phenotypic
analysis
of patient samples in the tumor
microenvironment is possible
the maxima imaging platform for ultra
high content imaging
hereby applies the renowned mix
technology
spatial immune cell distribution
including their phenotypes
is assessed within tissue and cell
conglomerates
by sequential staining of hundreds of
markers
in contrast traditional staining
techniques allow
maybe the staining of three to six
markers giving only an incomplete
picture
this analysis of hundreds of markers
within a single sample
includes of course automated sample
processing
and imaging of all types of fixed
samples from tissue
to single cells
on the other hand the light sheet
microscopes of the ultra microscope
family
enable you to visualize whole biological
systems in 3d
moving the sample through the light
sheets allows the generation of sharp
and bright
3d images of for example the tumor micro
environment
thereby really giving full insight into
the tumor immune cell
interactions please have a look
at this impressive video taken with the
ultra microscope too
it shows a mouse xenograft of a human
pancreatic carcinoma cell line with
infiltrating car t cells
in 3d
as mentioned before the variety of our
tsa products is best organized in
comprehensive workflows following your
scientific interest
consequently please find here listed our
highlight application workflows
our highlights include polarization of t
cells with protocols and cytokine
combinations
for the most efficient polarization of
your cd4 positive t helper cells
the regulatory t cell workflow with all
needed solutions for the isolation as
well as the expansion and analysis
of rare t-rex in a translational setting
the cartesian research workflow covering
all steps from t cell isolation to
activation to transduction
and finally car t potion potency
analysis
for fully translational and functional
generation of car key cells in a
research
setting the tilt workflow to efficiently
dissociate tumor tissue and isolate even
the rarest tumor infiltrating leukocytes
the antigen-specific t-cell workflow
optimized for the specific stimulation
of antigen-reactive t
cells as well as the isolation and
analysis of these extremely rare cells
in different contexts
and finally the covit-19 virus-specific
t-cell workflow that covers each step
from stimulation to enrichment to
analysis of sarskof2 reactive t
cells especially important in the
current situation
although that was quite an extensive
overview of the t-cell portfolio you
have to remember
only three easy things we offer more
than just these
separation we cover the whole t-cell
workflow
and we offer a solution to every pain
point
so have all the success with your with
our innovative and complete t-cell
portfolio
as displayed here in this full-featured
overview
before we end please acknowledge the
display disclaimer
hereby i close with this nice picture of
our company campus in baggage gladbach
at night
please visit our website
www.miltonybiodect.com
to get more info on the mentioned
workflows and products in the forms of
application pages
protocols and of course in-depth
webinars
so thank you very much for your
attention